I respect this court
but I'm innocent I would never
under any circumstances hurt my wife
Maggie and I would never under any
circumstances hurt my son Papa
he still says he didn't do it but a jury
of his peers disagreed Alex Murdoch
found guilty of murdering his son Paul
and wife Maggie and sentenced to life in
prison it's a stunning fall for the
disgraced attorney whose family not only
practiced law in a tiny South Carolina
town for a century they were the law
that is until Alex went from lawyer to
defendant the judge tearing down that
dynasty
your family
including you
have been Prosecuting people here in
this courtroom
and many have received
the death penalty
probably for lesser conduct and the
question is when will it end
when will it end
and it it's ended already for the jury
because they've concluded that you
continue to lie and lie
throughout your testimony the judge also
had this chilling warning for the
convicted murderer
I know you have to
see Paul and Maggie during the night
times when you're attempting to go to
sleep
I'm sure they come and visit you
sure
and every night
and in the end it was the tape that got
murdered one juror said this video put
him directly at the murder scene and
sealed his fate
he started deliberating going through
the evidence
everybody was pretty much talking
and
only about 45 minutes later we
after all our
deliberate and we figured it out the
evidence was clear did you feel like he
was a liar a good liar
but
not good enough
but this isn't the last year here of
Murdoch his defense vowing to appeal and
take it all the way to the Supreme Court
if they have to also there's still the
matter of all the money he stole from
the law firm he faces 700 years in
prison for that
all right Greg I mean I think the juror
said it right there I mean he was a liar
and he was a good liar but not good
enough it's got to suck being that
remaining son if I were him I would be
right now changing my last name
something less inflammatory like Bin
Laden Foster Bin Laden yes
um it kind of this kind of sucks in a
way because he got a life sentence and
within that phrase is the word life and
with Psychopaths they can adapt to
anything right he's still good he's
still gonna get three meals a day he's
still gonna get like an hour of sunlight
his wife and kid are dead but it's it's
when you a life sentence I don't think
people understand it that is not a fate
worse than death these sociopaths
Psychopaths they that they don't want to
die he should have been he should get
the death penalty O.J Simpson chimed in
I don't know if you saw that said that
there was a possibility you should have
been acquitted but you know he is the
expert I see CNN uh replacement for
Jeffrey tuben uh right there uh but I
didn't realize like how awful this
family is yeah I didn't realize I mean
if you're around that family you have a
50 chance of being murdered I mean so
many untimely mysterious deaths I mean
they make the clintons look like the
Cleavers Hillary's like looking at this
going boy that guy's got game you know
but I I and I thought the judge I
thought the judge was really good except
when he said
uh he said maybe you didn't kill him
maybe
you killed them on drugs remember he
said and it's like you don't blame drugs
you blame the person you blame that
person there are people who do drugs
that don't kill their family but it was
like don't don't it was almost like a
partial exoneration like you know maybe
it wasn't you it was just you were under
the thrall of this demon it's like
that's that's because the only person I
feel really bad for is Judge Jeanine uh
she bet Tyrus you see that no what
happened she bet Tyrus her house that it
would be a hung jury so me and Tyler
just rented a U-Haul and we're heading
up after the five to get his weight room
stuff in it's a pretty big house very
good you might notice
uh your thoughts on the on the verdict
and on the sentence so to your point
about a life sentence being a walk in
the park sometimes well this was a
transcript of his conversation with
Buster Bin Laden I guess what we're
calling him now uh man I hit nine out of
11 games on the Sunday pro games I won
like six soups and four beef sticks so
he will be well fed but that's a point
like he already found a way to have fun
yes he'll be just fine but look I would
say that there was Reasonable Doubt in
this case which is why it was shocking
to me that in 45 minutes the jurors came
to that conclusion Reasonable Doubt
there were brown hair strands in Maggie
Murdoch's hand why weren't they tested
why wasn't DNA tested on the bodies all
of these questions can be asked but they
didn't believe his emotion I agreed with
the judge this would be a hung jury
because of the emotion that I saw no
mother or father wants to think about
someone killing their child and their
wife but apparently the juror said there
were no tears he said there was a lot of
snot but there were no tears I actually
think we have that let's listen to that
you have the snot we have that snap
right here in my cup I didn't think much
of them really really
I didn't see any
true remorse
or
any compassion or anything even though
he was he cried a lot on the stand he
never cried
he never cried what do you mean by that
all he did was blue snot did you not see
tears no tears how did you know he
wasn't crying because I stole his eyes
that was this close to him
you know Kelly when you see it through
the TV screen as we've been analyzing it
it's a lot different when you're
adjourned you're in that courtroom you
get a different take a lot different
because we saw on outnumbered we would
cover this during the day his face
turned red kind of touched his face it
looked like tears he certainly lied in
that way but it doesn't appear that it
was this will be appealed uh but
interesting they want to take it to the
Supreme Court they have to have a
federal question and they point to the
doyle case which says we can and for
Guilt from Silence he was in silence
this was a man who lied so good luck
with that why don't they have the death
penalty in this situation here I mean
South Carolina right it is South
Carolina where they do have it and I'm
not sure Kelly's the lawyer at the table
so I I would seed my time no we don't
have to we all Pretend We're lawyers
here oh
it's a disadvantage yeah yeah
against the death penalty so and I do
think that being locked in a tiny box
for the rest of your life whether you're
a sociopath or not because he won't be
on 60 oxies a day he'll just be sitting
there and his is this true you can't get
oxy in prison at all
not 60. probably just one or two right
um so I don't know about the death
penalty question for this
um I think the point of this being a
show is really relevant and the fact
that the Netflix show came out last week
which definitely as it was being
televised really hyped up the attention
to it it was the number one show on
there and I think that's where people to
your point Greg really got a feel for
how terrible all these people were so
pawpaw yeah who killed Mallory the young
girl on the boat
um his his best friend's girlfriend who
went flying off as he crashed he
directly crashed that boat and then I
thought the most powerful part of the
Netflix special of this and relevant to
the story is the manipulation of every
generation of this family in the
hospital so the grandfather mother
Alec and the sun all playing defense
going around to different hospital rooms
manipulating children and their parents
saying where do I present you we've got
your best interests at heart and then
trying to pin it on another kid that he
was the one who was driving the boat you
know people are gross to the Bone when
they're doing that the housekeeper their
beloved housekeeper who raised the kids
pushing her down a flight of stairs and
stealing 4.3 million dollars from her
children they had no idea that a benefit
claim had been taken out on their lives
and then the suspected murder of Steven
Smith I think was his name
um someone who was allegedly involved in
homosexual relationship with Buster that
could no justice for that family
um and I would recommend it's not like I
have no investment in Netflix for this
but it does seeing it played out like
that did make a difference to me
um for sure and I thought that the juror
was very good though there are some
people who cry without tears I
show us now all show I'm actually crying
and you guys never know what's happening
not an actor or a lawyer so neither one
um my perspective on just who this
person is
is that he thought he was going to get
away with killing his wife and his son I
mean this went untouched for what nine
months before it was actually
investigated he didn't think anything
was going to happen as a result of this
and then when he stood up there in front
of the jury acting it out arrogantly
thinking I'm a lawyer I can out
strategize these people I can act on my
way through this these are just stupid
people who are who are lesser than I am
I'm a very prominent important person
who's been able to get away with all of
these things for my entire life and my
family name is worth a lot more than
these people's opinions and it didn't
work and sitting in that courtroom those
people listened to the facts they went
and visited the crime scene and they
came up with the conclusion that Not
only was he guilty but his big act for
days on the stand was a big lie and when
you do that to a jury they don't tend to
have much doubt about the crimes that
you've committed all right well said hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else